a justice league movie by the man who
brought you mad max the ghostbusters
taking on the devil himself this isn't
just fantasy this was almost real life
would these movies have worked on the
big screen
space jam is a cinematic oddity if there
ever was one in a true time capsule of
the 90s the film's development arose
from the line of hair jordan commercials
featuring both michael jordan and bugs
bunny promoting air jordan shoes the
film was a slam dunk at the box office
bringing in
250.2 million dollars on an 80 million
dollar budget naturally a sequel seemed
like the logical next move for warner
brothers but this was easier said than
done bob camp best known for his work on
the ren and stimpy show was tasked with
designing a new alien threat for the
sequel sadly michael jordan bowed out of
the project which was contingent on his
involvement so the second installment
was shelved in the following years
various sequel concepts would be pitched
partially developed and then abandoned
or reshaped into something else this
includes spy jam which would have
starred action icon jackie chan race jam
which would have starred nascar driver
jeff gordon and even skate jam which
would have been built around
professional skateboarder tony hawk
although any one of these pitches
certainly had the potential to be a hit
none of them made it out of the
development phase and onto the big
screen the prospect of a sequel didn't
reach fruition until 2021 with the
release of space jam a new legacy
featuring lebron james
if you've ever wondered why it's taken
so long for a third proper ghostbusters
film to see the light of day you're not
alone but there's a good reason for it
the idea of a third installment in the
paranormal comedy franchise was first
conceived shortly after the release of
ghostbusters 2. the three quote as
indicated by the title of ghostbusters
hell bent would have taken place in an
alternate manhattan known as man helton
this would naturally lead to the
ghostbusters taking on their biggest
threat to date the devil himself the
idea remained in limbo for many years
largely due to a lack of interest from
bill murray in reprising his role as
peter venkman it was eventually decided
the film would respectfully pass the
torch to a new team of quirky paranormal
investigators rather than the original
cast while several a-list comedians were
name-dropped at the time including chris
farley nothing concrete ever
materialized mainly due to colombia's
concern over the lackluster performance
of ghostbusters 2. in the multiple
drafts of the script that failed to
impress murray and produces alike the
ill-fated third ghostbusters film would
enter an eternal state of quite
fittingly development hell
the year was 2008 and sam raimi was
still licking his wounds from the poor
reception of spider-man 3. raymie has
gone on record in years since
attributing the film's critical failure
to studio meddling from sony pictures
specifically the fourth edition of venom
a villain whom raymie didn't fully
understand or wish to include despite
the third entry in the series performing
well at the box office there seemed to
be little faith that a fourth would
materialize raymie was still passionate
about the project however and opted to
move forward himself going as far as to
commission a screenplay in storyboards
commissioned illustrator jeffrey
henderson made his artwork available
online to show fans what could have been
based on his storyboards one of the
film's main antagonists was planned to
be adrian toombs otherwise known as the
vulture it was ramey's intention to
reboot public perception of the more
obscure character which could have
solidified him as one of the web head's
most infamous enemies additionally there
would have also been an appearance from
mysterio potentially played by evil dead
star bruce campbell who had previously
made cameos in all three spider-man
films so far
remy's spider-man 4 would have gone to
some amazing and unexplored places and
we'd like to believe fans would have
loved it sadly despite the director's
efforts sony didn't see any value in the
fourth film and in 2010 officially
killed the project rebooting the
franchise instead with mark webb at the
helm and andrew garfield in the starring
role
though not quite as popular as god of
war or jack and daxter the sly cooper
games are beloved by playstation owners
of all ages for their unique art style
and stealth based gameplay the series
focuses on master thief sly cooper and
his partners in crime bentley the turtle
and murray the hippo pursued by interpol
inspector carmelita fox the trio balance
a life of high stakes thievery and
globetrotting adventure with a premise
like that a film adaptation sounds like
a no-brainer that would lend itself
quite well to the world of animation a
teaser trailer arrived in january 2014
animated by mainframe studios at the
time known as rainmaker entertainment
but that was the only piece of the film
that ever made its way to public eyes a
major factor foreshadowing the project's
termination was the poor box office
performance of ratchet and clank in
2016. the film also animated by
rainmaker and based on a classic
playstation title only grows 14.4
million dollars against its 20 million
dollar budget following this development
rainmaker was dropped from the project
and everything sadly imploded from there
despite rumblings of a television series
there have been no major updates for
animated adaptations of sly cooper since
and with the latest game in the series
having been released all the way back in
2013 the future of sly cooper isn't
looking terribly bright
the beatles a simple name for one of the
most prominent and influential groups
not just in rock and roll but in music
as a whole composed of john lennon paul
mccartney george harrison and ringo
starr the group was behind some of
history's most noteworthy albums and
songs the group starred as fictionalized
versions of themselves in several
feature films including help and a hard
day's night but none of them have had
the same lasting impact as 1968's yellow
submarine the yellow submarine movie is
a surreal and captivating animated romp
that perfectly captures the absurd
images described in the original label
upon release the film received rave
reviews and is hailed as a landmark
achievement in the animated world to
this day the film's legacy was so
enduring that in 2009 disney recruited
back to the future director robert
zemeckis to craft a new version
zemeckis's yellow submarine was set to
be made using the same motion capture
animation style as the polar express
unfortunately the project was shuttered
by disney in 2011 due in part to the
critical and box office disasters that
were mars needs moms and a christmas
carol zemeckis attempted to shop the
idea around to other studios but
ultimately gave up on the project in
2012. since then there have been no
further attempts to remake the original
1960s animated classic
since the big budget retelling of dune
has arrived it's important to remember
the cinematic adaptation that never was
that movie would have been the biggest
and most ambitious science fiction film
made up to that point and it would have
been directed by alejandro jodorowsky
one of the most artistically daring
creators in all of cinema his most
famous works el topo and the holy
mountain have both been praised for
their surreal yet violent visuals
following the success of the holy
mountain jodorowsky was offered the
funding to helm a cinematic adaptation
of frank herbert's doom he of course
accepted the offer and began work on the
massive artistic undertaking per lavish
agreement to have his favorite chef cook
employed throughout the production the
legendary orson welles signed on to
portray the evil baron harkonnen the
visuals would have been crafted by dan
o'bannon and h.r gieger most famous for
the nightmarish designs of ridley
scott's alien finally perhaps most
impressively the film's soundtrack would
have been performed in part by legendary
rock band pink floyd unfortunately
jodorowsky's vision proved too
unfeasible for any major studio and the
adaptation rights were eventually sold
off they were picked up by italian
producer dino de laurentiis resulting in
david lynch's now infamous adaptation
from 1984.
stanley kubrick is a name synonymous
with both cinematic brilliance and
problematic genius kubrick was a master
of pushing the art of cinema to its most
absurd possibilities into breathtaking
results on the flip side he was known
for a harsh and borderline abusive
attitude when directing his films
especially toward his actors for all his
legendary work kubrick wasn't always
successful with his cinematic
undertakings case in point his most
notable cancelled film napoleon after
rapping on 2001 a space odyssey kubrick
looked to direct a sizably budgeted film
about french emperor napoleon bonaparte
kubrick had an active fascination with
the historical figure that dated back to
his early childhood obsessed with making
the film as accurate as possible kubrick
insisted on watching every previous
napoleon film available he even went as
far as to replicate napoleon's real life
diet in order to fully immerse himself
in bonaparte's habits and mindset the
film much like kubrick's other works
would have been predicated heavily on
immense detail from the sets to the
costumes it was a project that kubrick
was truly passionate about pauline is
still in his grave
waiting to be brought back to life sadly
due to the prohibitive cost of shooting
on location as well as the box office
disappointment of 1970s waterloo the
project was scrapped it was a
disappointing end to what could have
been one of the greatest period war
films and character studies ever put to
celluloid
pixar is one of the most successful
names in mainstream animation and it's
impossible not to see why with films
like the toy story series finding nemo
up and countless others the studio has
captivated countless children and adults
however there was one pixar project that
was apparently immune to the studio's
magic the film newt would have followed
the last remaining male and female
blue-footed nukes a duo forced to work
together to repopulate their species
even though they can't stand each other
clearly the project had lots of
potential for comedy and heart but that
wasn't enough to get it off the ground
the film's development remained very
stagnant in the years following its 2008
announcement and a few years later it
was officially announced that newt had
been scrapped by pixar making it the
only film in the studio's history to be
announced and later canceled it's
unclear what the true death blow was for
newt because there were actually several
likely contributing factors the most
likely reason was its similarities to
another animated film that was in
production at the time blue sky studios
rio
universal pictures correctly flagging
e.t the extraterrestrial as a surefire
hit approached steven spielberg about a
sequel shortly before the original's
release spielberg usually known for not
doing sequels expressed interest and
developed a nine-page treatment for a
follow-up this treatment which has been
available online for years was titled
et2 nocturnal fears nocturnal fears
would have followed the core cast from
the original contending with another far
deadlier alien encounter a mutated
faction of e.t species would abduct
elliott along with his friends at the
climax of the film et would make a
dramatic return to vanquish the evil
aliens and save his earthling friends
nocturnal fears was written to be a more
mature story a far cry from the
family-friendly nature of the original
this is evident in the film's treatment
which describes the alien's horrific
treatment of the kids especially poor
elliott who is interrogated and implied
to be tortured eventually spielberg
returned to his original stance against
sequels and opted not to pursue any
follow-up to e.t it's fair to say that
if released et2 nocturnal fears would
have been a profitable hollywood sequel
but based on the film's bizarre plot and
tone it's debatable as to how well the
film would have been critically received
while fans are undoubtedly glad the
snyder cut finally saw the light of day
there is one justice league film that no
one will ever see no matter how much
they ask for it back in 2007 just before
the beginning of the marvel cinematic
universe warner brothers and dc comics
were planning something big wb struck a
deal with husband and wife duo michelle
and karen mulroney to pin a massive
justice league film meant to pave the
way for sequels and various spin-offs
for individual heroes the script was
completed and the studio quickly put the
wheels in motion to find a director up
to the task after a long search the
powers that be decided on george miller
director of the mad max franchise
production ultimately made it to the
casting phase where young actors were
given the chance to breathe new life
into dc's legendary characters some of
the names chosen were dj katrona as
superman army hammer as batman and adam
brodie as the flash sadly the production
experienced numerous delays and setbacks
due mainly to the
2007-2008 writers guild of america
strike additionally a discrepancy
between wb and the australian government
regarding an incentive tax rebate for
film production only compounded matters
further after the dark knight took the
world by storm in 2008 justice league
mortal was officially scrapped
how many times can you be told no before
it's finally time to throw in the tower
for good well if you're guillermo del
toro you might be so utterly dedicated
to your vision that you'll never give up
del toro is best known for creating
lavish settings and otherworldly
creatures that nearly defied description
as we've seen in his genre bending films
like pan's labyrinth and his best
picture winner the shape of water del
toro has been making visionary films for
decades and shows no signs of slowing
down h.p lovecraft's 1931 novella at the
mountains of madness is the tale of a
group of explorers stranded in the
antarctic who are slowly picked off one
by one by an otherworldly terror it's
not surprising that del toro fought long
and hard to helm the first adaptation of
the horrific tale the pet project was
announced over a decade ago but nothing
has materialized since much to the
disappointment of del toro himself the
eventual cancellation of the project
stemmed from a few factors most notably
disputes over the film's rating while
universal studios was dead set on a
pg-13 rating del toro stuck to his guns
and continually push for an r-rated film
del toro has gone on record saying the
mpaa rating issue was the nail in the
coffin for the project that's too bad as
it would have likely been one of the
best adaptations of any lovecraft story
to date
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you